>>> AN EXPLOSIVE NEW MEMOIR IS
GIVING A STUNNINGLY CANDID LOO
AT FORMER PRESIDENT NALD
TRUMP, DETAILING THE MANY
ILLEGAL ACTIONS TRUMP AND HIS
AIDES WERE SUGGESTING TO TOP
MILITARY BRASS, SUCH AS SHOOTING
AMERICAN PROTESTORS IN THE
NATION'S CAPITOL.
OR FIRING MISSILES ON MEXICAN
DRUG LABS.
WITHHOLDING AID TO UKRAINE THAT
CONGRESS HAD SIGNED OFF ON, AND
ON ONE OCCASION, SUGGESTING THE
U.S. PUBLICLY BRANDISH THE
BLOODIED HEAD OF ISIS LEADER AL
BAGHDADI AS A TROPHY.
ALL THIS IN HIS NEW BOOK,
WRITTEN BY TRUMP'S DEFENSE
SECRETARY MARK ESPER.
HE SERVED IN THAT POSITION FROM
JULY 2019 TO NOVEMBER 2020, ONLY
TO BE FIRED BY A TWEET SIX DAYS
AFTER THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
HE JOINS US NOW.
SECRETARY ESPER, I WANT TO ASK
YOU ABOUT THOSE SHOCKING CLAIMS
IN A MOMENT.
BUT FIRST, THE NEWS OF THE DAY.
WE FOUND OUT THAT THE HOUSE
SELECT COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING
THE INSURRECTION IS SENDING
SUBPOENAS TO KEVIN McCARTHY AND
FOUR OTHER HOUSE REPUBLICANS.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION?
>> YOU KNOW, JAKE, AS YOU
MENTIONED, IT'S BREAKING NEWS.
I HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO FIND
OUT WHAT'S GOING ON.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT AT THE
END OF THE DAY THAT THE JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF WHAT HAPPENED AND UNDERSTAND
IT.
MAKE SURE THERE IS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND PREVENT THIS
FROM HAPPENING AGAIN.
IT WAS A TRAGIC DAY IN OUR
NATION'S HISTORY.
>> WE LEARNED IN HE CENT DAYS
THAT KEVIN McCARTHY WAS THINKING
ABOUT AT ONE POINT OR DISCUSSING
INVOKING THE 25th AMENDMENT THAT
ALLOWS A PRESIDENT TO BE REMOVED
FROM OFFICE.
HE WAS DOING THIS IN THE DAYS
AFTER JANUARY 6th.
HE CONCLUDED IT WOULD TAKE TOO
LONG.
THERE ARE TAPES OF HIM SAYING
THIS.
IN YOUR BOOK, YOU SAID YOU NEVER
BELIEVED TRUMP'S CONDUCT ROSE TO
THE LEVEL OF INVOKING THE 25th
AMENDMENT.
IF YOU HAD BEEN DEFENSE
SECRETARY IN THE DAYS AFTER
JANUARY 6th, WOULD YOU HAVE
VOTED TO REMOVE HIM FROM OFFICE?
>> JAKE, YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW.
YOU HAVE TO BE THERE IN THE
MOMENT TO UNDERSTAND AND ASSESS
THE SITUATION AND HAVE A CHANCE
TO, YOU KNOW, LOOK AT THE
PRESIDENT UNDER FIRE IN THAT
MOMENT.
CLEARLY, WHAT HE DID WAS
ANTI-THREAT CALL TO WHAT WE
BELIEVE IN AS A DEMOCRACY.
HE INCITED PEOPLE TO COME TO
D.C., STIRRED THEM UP AND FAILED
TO COME THEM OFF.
IN MY MIND, THAT IS UNDERMINING
OUR DEMOCRACY.
SO, YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW WHERE
I WOULD HAVE STOOD, BUT I WOULD
HAVE TAKEN A SERIOUS LOOK AT IT
AND I THINK COME TO THE PROPER
JUDGMENT.
>> WE'VE SEEN IN RECENT MONTHS
THE IMPORTANCE OF UKRAINE
GETTING THAT MILITARY AID THAT
DONALD TRUMP TRIED TO HOLD UP
INITIALLY DURING THE ACTIONS
THAT LED TO HIS FIRST
IMPEACHMENT.
IN YOUR BOOK, YOU SAY YOU
REPEATEDLY WARNED DONALD TRUMP
THAT WITHHOLDING MILITARY AID TO
UKRAINE WAS NOT ONLY ILLEGAL,
BUT IT WOULD FURTHER WEAKEN
ZELENSKYY'S GOVERNMENT.
IN HIND SIGHT, LOOKING BACK ON
IT, DO YOU THINK TRUMP'S
RESISTANCE TO HELPING UKRAINE,
THE WAY THAT HE BEHAVED TOWARDS
ZELENSKYY, DO YOU THINK THAT
EMBOLDENED PUTIN IN ANY WAY TO
ACT AS AGGRESSIVELY AS WE'RE
SEEING TODAY?
>> WELL, FIRST THING'S FIRST.
YOU KNOW, IT IS TRUE, I TALK
ABOUT THIS, JOHN BOLTON, THE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER, MIKE
POMPEO, THE SECRETARY OF STATE
AND I AT VARIOUS TIMES WOULD
ENGAGE INDIVIDUALLY OR TOGETHER
WITH THE PRESIDENT AND TALK HIM
INTO RELEASING THIS FUNDING FOR
A VARIETY OF REASONS.
JUST FIRST TO BOLSTER THIS
DEMOCRACY TO DETER RUSSIA.
AND FOR ME, IT WAS THE LAW THAT
CONGRESS HAD APPROPRIATED IT.
THAT SAID, YOU KNOW, I DON'T
THINK IT MADE A MATERIAL
DIFFERENCE.
IT WAS THREE YEARS AGO AT THIS
POINT.
I DO WANT TO GIVE THE PRESIDENT
CREDIT.
I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION DID
THE RIGHT THING BY PROVIDING
LETHAL AID IN THE FORM OF THE
JAVELINS.
AND THEN, OF COURSE, CONDUCTING
TRAINING IN WESTERN UKRAINE,
WHICH I HAD THE CHANCE TO VISIT.
I'M NOT SURE THREE YEARS LATER
IT HAD A MATERIAL IMPACT ON
WHAT'S HAPPENING TODAY.
>> YOU WRITE THAT TRUMP ALWAYS
HAD A SOFT SPOT FOR PUTIN.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
HE TENDED TO HAVE THAT SAME SOFT
SPOT FOR OTHER STRONG MEN,
WHETHER IT WAS PUTIN OR XI
JINPING.
AND I COULDN'T EXPLAIN IT.
IT IS JUST WHAT IT WAS.
IN SOME WAYS I THINK AS I WRITE
WITH REGARD TO OUR CHINA POLICY,
AND I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION
WAS SUCCESSFUL IN CONSOLIDATING
AN AMERICAN CONSENSUS, IF YOU
WILL, THAT CHINA IS A STRATEGIC
ADVERSARY, BUT HIS WILLINGNESS
TO ENGAGE XI JINPING AND TREAT
HIM AS A FRIEND IN SOME WAYS
UNDERMINED THAT.
>> IN YOUR BOOK, YOU SAY TRUMP
AND AIDES WERE SUGGESTING IDEAS
SUCH AS SHOOTING AMERICAN
PROTESTORS IN THE NATION'S
CAPITOL, USING THE MILITARY TO
STAY IN POWER, BOMBING AMERICA'S
NEIGHBOR IN MEXICO, AND DIPPING
AL BAGHDADI'S HEAD IN PIG'S
BLOOD.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO CRITICS WHO
SAY THE TIME TO SHARE THOSE
STORIES WAS BEFORE THE 2020
ELECTION SO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
COULD MAKE AN INFORMED CHOICE,
NOT NOW WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO
SELL BOOKS?
>> WELL, LOOK, IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION AND AN ISSUE I
STRUGGLED WITH THROUGH A GOOD
PART OF MY TENURE.
I WRITE ABOUT THIS IN THE
OPENING PAGES, SHOULD I STAY OR
SHOULD I GO?
MY VIEW WAS, AT THE END OF THE
DAY, GIVEN I HAD THE CHANCE TO
CONTINUE ADVANCING GOOD
INITIATIVES AT THE PENTAGON,
RIGHT?
BUILDING OUR CYBER CAPABILITIES,
PROPOSING A NEW NAVY,
MODERNIZING THE ARMED FORCES,
BUILDING TRUST WITH ALLIES AND
PARTNERS, BETWEEN THAT AND THE
FACT THAT I WAS ABLE
SUCCESSFULLY OVER A PERIOD OF
MONTHS TO PUSH BACK ON THESE
OUTLANDISH IDEAS, I THOUGHT MY
HIGHER SENSE OF DUTY WAS TO THE
COUNTRY TO STAY, NOT LEAVE.
I WOULD HAVE SAVED ME A LOT OF
GRIEF AND HEARTACHE TO WALK
AWAY, BUT I DIDN'T THINK THAT
WOULD PUT THE COUNTRY IN THE
RIGHT POSITION.
I CONSULTED FOLKS FROM BOTH
PARTIES, EVEN THE LATE COLIN
POWELL, WHO SAID YOU HAVE TO
STAY.
MY GOAL WAS TO GET TO THE
ELECTION AND CONTINUE TO TRY TO
ADVANCE A POSITIVE AGENDA WITHIN
THE PENTAGON.
>> AND YOU SAY IN THE BOOK THAT
YOU NEVER PUBLICLY REBUKED TRUMP
WHILE YOU WERE DEFENSE SECRETARY
BECAUSE YOU THOUGHT HE WOULD
TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO FIRE
YOU, AND YOU NEVER RESIGNED,
BECAUSE YOU WORRIED TRUMP WOULD
REPLACE YOU WITH A LOYALIST,
SOMEBODY THAT WOULD CARRY OUT
ANY ORDER.
YOU WRITE ABOUT HOW AT LEAST IN
ONE INSTANCE, TRUMP'S LOYALISTS
WOULD WORK AROUND YOU IN WAYS.
STEVEN MILLER, FOR EXAMPLE,
DIRECTED THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY TO DEVELOP A
CONCEPT TO DEPLOY 200,000 PLUS
U.S. TROOPS TO THE BORDER, EVEN
AFTER YOU TOLD HIM THAT WAS NOT
POSSIBLE.
YOU WRITE "I WAS SHOCKED.
I ASKED QUESTIONS NO ONE HAD
GOOD ANSWERS FOR, HOW FAR ALONG
WERE THAT?
I WAS FRUSTRATED THAT ONE SENIOR
IN NORTH COM THOUGHT TO LET US
OR ANYONE AT THE PENTAGON FOR
THAT MATTER KNOW.
IT'S REALLY QUITE A SHOCKING
REVELATION.
HOW OFTEN DO YOU THINK THINGS
LIKE THAT WERE GOING ON THAT YOU
DIDN'T WATCH UNTIL TOWARDS THE
VERY END SN -- END?
OR MAYBE NOT AT ALL?
>> THERE WERE THINGS THAT
HAPPENED AND PICKED UP MORE
TOWARD THE END OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
BUT YOU KNOW, FIRST THING'S
FIRST.
YOU MENTIONED PUBLICLY REBUKING
HIM.
OF COURSE, I DID ON JUNE 3rd.
I CAME OUT AND PUBLICLY SPOKE
ABOUT INNOVATION OF THE
INSURRECTION ACT.
I HAD TO SPEAK OUT WHEN HE
PROPOSED BOMBING IRANIAN
CULTURAL AND HISTORIC SITES.
I SAID NO, THE U.S. MILITARY
DOESN'T DO THAT.
GOING BACK TO THE EDDIE
GALLAGHER EPISODE IN THE FALL OF
2019, I SAID I HOPED THE
PRESIDENT WOULD ALLOW THE
MILITARY PROCESS TO WORK ITS WAY
THROUGH.
SO THERE WERE TIMES I HAD TO DO
THAT.
BUT AFTER JUNE, FOR EXAMPLE, I
WAS TRYING NOT TO GET IN CROSS
WISE WITH THE PRESIDENT, BECAUSE
THERE WAS SO MUCH GOING ON, AND
THESE OUTLANDISH IDEAS KEPT
COMING FORWARD.
I WANTED TO MAKE SURE I DIDN'T
GET FIRED TOO SOON.
I WANTED TO BE THERE TO ABOUT IN
WHAT I THOUGHT WAS THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE COUNTRY.
I HAD TO BE ON GUARD, AS DID
GENERAL MILLEY, TO MAKE SURE
FOLKS WEREN'T GOING AROUND US TO
DO THIS OR THAT.
I TALK ABOUT THOSE THINGS IN THE
BOOK.
>> I KNOW YOU SAID THAT YOU'LL
NEVER VOTE FOR DONALD TRUMP
AGAIN, AND YOU DON'T THINK HE
SHOULD BE PRESIDENT AGAIN.
WOULD YOU WORK FOR A REPUBLICAN
OR ENDORSE A REPUBLICAN IN THE
PRIMARY TO DEFEAT DONALD TRUMP
IF IT COMES TO THAT?
>> SURE, IF IT'S SOMEBODY I
BELIEVED IN, SOMEBODY THAT IS
PROMOTING TRADITIONAL REPUBLICAN
POLICIES, LIKE LOWER TAXES, A
STRONG DEFENSE, OF COURSE,
BORDER SECURITY, THINGS LIKE
THAT.
THEY HAVE TO BE A PERSON OF
INTEGRITY AND PRINCIPLE AND PUT
COUNTRY ABOVE SELF AND UNIFY THE
COUNTRY.
SO IF SOMEBODY MEETS CRITERIA
LIKE, THAT ABSOLUTELY I WOULD
SUPPORT THEM.
>> FORMER DEFENSE SECRETARY MARK
ESPER, THANK YOU